so I had to Define myself in this
situation you ask became a professional
killer
and yeah it's a day job
but I'm happy to get my hands bleeding
filthy for the right price needed to
keep my head down after what happened
back in London so I'll grab my fake
passport and hops on the first flight to
anywhere which turned out to be Malta
there's more people need killing in this
corner of the world than I can keep up
with I might be able to help you out
this is our lab where he tries all of
his new techniques and where I can have
a bash you've seen if they're actually
going to work in the real world
how'd you find me Ray I heard that
you've got a nice little learner going
on down here nothing we've got going on
down here is going to bother you you
have bothered me
no pain no gain amen
[Music]
it would seem that the CEOs put out a
contract on my son Dante I need you to
protect my son at all costs do you
understand there's a gaggle of Assassins
about to turn up kill every last one
year
so you better get your skates on
proper game on
[Applause]
him alive your marriage is hired me to
protect you okay
[Music]
I'm not safe with you you are a magnet
for Cycles you look like melted Ben
Affleck
[Music]
is it dead
it is now
all right Mike nice weekend not really
mate no